Welcome back everyone this would be my video
for warner brothers in dc just canceling a whole
bunch of their movies and tv shows like nobody
is safe now so i'll explain what's going on
even though it's been going on for a while
now this week they announced the official end
of the flash and the batgirl movie like big
surprise no more movie no more flash there are
like three or four big reasons why dc is taking
a flamethrower to a lot of its own movies and tv
shows right now but the circumstances for why
they're getting rid of the flash is a little
bit different from why they're throwing the
batgirl movie in the trash can metaphorically
what a week huh lemon it's wednesday the good
news is in all this they are still releasing
black adam and shazam 2 movies this year and
apparently test audiences so far really like both
of those movies so there is a sliver of hope in
there and i will do videos for both of those like
they just released a black adam trailer i'll do
a new video for that soon be sure to subscribe to
get everything there are tons of other movies and
big budget hbo tv series that they're working on
right now like the robert pattinson batman hbo
spin-offs that we heard about recently i've
already done videos about that so i'll link them
below in the description so it's not like dc is
blowing up everything that they have but as you
can tell they're like seismic shifts behind the
scenes like a whole bunch of people got fired
a bunch of new people came in and they're like
we're gonna do our new stuff now we're not gonna
do your old stuff but first things first pour one
out for the flash rip which is ending officially
now like we all thought that things were over when
they announced that they cancelled pretty much
all the other dc tv series earlier this year like
okay days are numbered for the flash it's pretty
much over now but what they announced is that it's
officially ending after a shortened season 9 which
was what a lot of people predicted earlier this
year so no big surprise there we all knew it was
coming but interestingly though the timing of the
flash tv show series finale like the very last
episode ever is going to air right before the
flash movie release date there's no big conspiracy
theory there or anything like that that's just the
way the timing lines up because all the seasons
got shifted just a little bit because of what
happened with the virus delays but the big news is
that apparently the flash movie is still a thing
i'll explain why because there's been so much talk
about recasting ezra miller as the flash in the dc
eu movies like if they're ending the flash tv show
literally right before the flash movie comes out
people are asking why don't you just say that
grant gustin is the movie flash right now
and nobody will ask any questions about it like
we literally already saw them cross over we know
that they exist in the same multiverse right
now currently that's not what they're doing
like that's not their plan but i definitely think
long term they are going to bring in a brand new
flash like somebody call up wally west on the bat
phone we need another flash in the movies stat the
reason why they're ending the flash tv show is
because there's this big seismic shift happening
in dc tv shows just in general not just the dc
tv aeroverse universe on the cw but all dc shows
on all networks basically dc is moving to a model
more like what marvel studios is doing right now
so like kevin feige now controls pretty much all
of marvel television whereas before a completely
different group of people were making marvel tv
shows under jeff loeb like the marvel netflix
defender shows like charlie cox's daredevil then
disney basically put kevin feige in charge of all
marvel tv they rolled out disney plus and they're
like okay we want people to subscribe to disney
plus so we're gonna put our crown jewel marvel and
star wars all the big stuff just on disney plus
so if you want that stuff you have to subscribe
to disney plus so now marvel's doing this thing
where they're trying to make shows that look
kind of like movies just broken into like six
or nine different episodes they're supposed to
feel like movie quality in comparison to a normal
tv show which might run for like 20 episodes like
the flash for instance and now warner brothers in
dc are wanting to do the same thing so they're
basically like pulling in all their iep and say
okay we're going to keep making tv shows but
there's going to be fewer episodes it's going
to be bigger budget and you'll have to get them
from hbo max now so that basically spelled the
end of the cw dc tv shows like some of them just
reached their natural end like they'd already
been running for many many seasons was like okay
let's just wrap things up after the next season
there are a couple exceptions like some of the
shows will survive but for instance like superman
and lois which a lot of people seem to really like
the quality seems like it's a little bit better
the special effects budget seems a little bit
bigger the showrunners on superman and lois were
the same showrunners from the flash previously
they just confirmed at the end of season 2 that
the superman and lois series is supposed to be
set in an alternate universe because they didn't
want to deal with the dc tv universe anymore like
they had diggle on superman and lois but they're
like no no this isn't the same dc tv diggle this
is like a completely separate universe version
of diggle all because they didn't want to have
anything to do with the dc tv universe so that
was like the final nail in the coffin like the
flash was like the last official dc tv show and
now obviously that is ending you also have to kind
of pour one out for the aeroverse like this is the
end of it even though we do have the multiverse
a lot of those actors will probably come back and
cameo on superman and lois as alternate universe
versions of characters so is the arrowverse really
dead kind of but not really it's really up to you
to decide we kind of went through the same thing
when they brought back charlie cox's daredevil
in spiderman no way home and now they're doing
the daredevil born again series with all the same
actors from the marvel netflix series on disney
plus but this is kind of the same version but
it's kind of a reimagining so it gets a little
bit confusing don't worry i will do videos for a
lot of these dc hbo shows like the big budget ones
when they start releasing them i just did videos
for peacemaker it's going to be kind of like that
the other big reason for them getting rid
of a lot of these cw dc tv shows is because
legit warner brothers is just selling off the cw
network like they're getting rid of the cw network
and because whoever buys the network won't be
making money off of these shows because they're
ending they're trying to cut a lot of the fat
so to speak like the money losers now for them
so that when they buy the network it just won't
cost them as much money they haven't said what
the official plot of the flash season 9 is going
to be but there have been teasers from them doing
a version of cobalt blue from the comics in the
comics he was barry's long-lost brother raised
by the thons which they don't really have on
the tv show like they haven't done a version
of barry's long-lost brother or anything like
that so they do another version of the character
like surprise this mystery character you never
expected is another type of speedster villain
and because it's the last season just like they
did during the arrow final season they'll probably
bring back all the biggest characters and actors
that the show has ever had and the ones that they
haven't done yet from the comics but like stephen
amell for instance has been teasing that he would
love to come back in cameo again as a version of
oliver queen he might come back in one of these
final episodes or the series finale the reason dc
and warner brothers canceled the batgirl movie is
a little bit different this is actually an even
bigger surprise like we expected the flash to end
sometime in the near future the batgirl movie
was like the news bomb that dropped this week
first of all it's a movie it's not a tv series but
also they literally already spent about 90 million
dollars making it and it's pretty much done like
they only had a little bit of post-production left
and the movie was literally gonna be finished and
now they're like you know what nope nobody's gonna
see it we're gonna throw it in the trash bin
michael keaton was in it as a version of batman
they also brought back the jk simmons version
of jim gordon from the dc eu he was going to
be barbara gordon's father they had a bunch of
easter eggs and references to the other dc eu
movies and they even had a bunch of nightwing
references everybody remembers once upon a time
there was a nightwing movie that they were making
the bigger surprise i think is that they're not
releasing it in any form on any platform in any
way that's what everybody's really blown away by
like there'll be no way of anyone seeing the movie
now short of someone breaking into warner brothers
and leaking the movie entirely there are a couple
reasons why they claim that they're doing that and
the biggest reason get it is because of a tax
loophole seriously it's just because of taxes
smarter lawyers have explained that there's a
special tax loophole available to dc and warner
brothers because of the big buyout situation
where they can basically write off the entire
cost of the movie and it doesn't have to be on
their balance sheet and the whole thing with
the new ceo of the company is that he's trying to
clear all this debt off their balance sheet so the
real reason for them getting rid of the batgirl
movie is mostly just coming down to numbers on a
balance sheet and the reason why they're not just
releasing it on home video later is because if
they use this special tax loophole which is only
available to them for like a brief window which
the batgirl movie falls in the loophole legally
states that they're not allowed to release the
movie in any form in any way because they didn't
have that stipulation like they wouldn't care like
they just put the movie on hbo max like they plan
to originally the real reason why they didn't just
decide to put it in theaters even if they didn't
think it was gonna make a ton of money to try and
make back some of the money and then release it
on blu-ray and home video later like put it on
digital like they'll make most of that money back
is because apparently according to the new ceo the
movie does not meet their standards of quality for
the dc movies that they want to start putting out
so basically they kind of feel like the movie
is so mid that they're willing to eat 90 million
dollars can you imagine how bad a movie has to be
for them to think that eating 90 million dollars
is a better outcome for them that's the real
reason why everyone's so blown away like what
you've already spent 90 million dollars just
like literally put it on hbo max who cares
we'll see if this winds up sticking we'll see
if they reverse their position later on because
nothing seems like it's set in stone like thanos
unsnap the batgirl movie now everybody's wondering
if the blue beetle movie is safe because that was
also going to be one of those hbo max low budget
movies that they were producing by all accounts
the blue beetle movie sounds like it's going to
be pretty decent and like i said test screenings
of shazam 2 in the black adam movie seemed like
they were really positive so it sounds like those
movies are going to be pretty decent so there
is like a sliver of hope out there and i think
honestly that they're just hoping that things will
blow over with the flash movie by the time that
it gets released next summer because it's going
to be a long time before that movie comes out i
might not have as much experience as you because
i'm not super old like you but i've seen all of
the fast and the furious movies lady it's all
about family i will do videos for all the stuff
that they do wind up releasing like i said i do
have plans to do videos for all the big hbo dc
series and obviously the movies that do wind up
making it to theaters my new black adam trailer
video will probably post in the next day or two
make sure you enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss that everyone click here for my
brand new guardians of the galaxy 3 trailer video
and click here for my brand new star wars and or
trailer thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!